turn around show me what you got you one  pound pound Chuck a knife take it up a  notch oh my god Wow take a mile let me  take a seat down step back heist music  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  it's some kind of monster  wait that's not a mobster that's a man  wearing shoulder pads there's only one  super villain whose fashion sense is  quite dead dating free  Balthazar Blatt I want every agent of  the scene immediately  hey mr. C are closing fast yes wait why  what did you call us  Brucie you know GRU and Lucy pushed  together GRU see aha  I like it but not a lot I don't like him  getting away  that's what do you think  get the ready for  Oh  hello glue haha what about that school  Wow Oh girls  wha yeah dance fight demo Nakao mm-hmm  this is not over  day to you happy birthday dear day  and happy birthday who's bad  [Music]  you